hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing now
we got hot dog into hot dog and we got a
whole lot of bad things that happened
when we released the demon doll from
Stern's Ranch but all that aside we've
got a whole bunch of other things here
so I'm gonna start from Butterfield and
I'm gonna go north and then I'm gonna
hit railroad and see where that leads me
because I'm part of this I don't know
where to go ooh mind stuff Stan told on
the side which is the worst grammar
you've ever seen even at a time and
place notable for its poor grammar Oh
burner up you pry the lid off the crate
and help yourself to the contents which
are now your stuff dynamite and can of
kerosene okay all right all righty then
oh hi hello how's it going
Oh No Oh cow guess we'd better do
something about that we're running away
that counts as something okay head Cal
gonna have to deal with this cow if you
want to explore this area all right you
ding-dong damn cow my whale you a hay
maker some pretty dicks these guys cut
tough this guy's got a lot of health to
him all right well I'm a muscle-up get
real beefy and I'm gonna poison you
Daboo skeet cuz that poison damage to
the whole bunch a lot but you got a lot
of he'll ah you missed me ha ha take
some of that how about a varmint
skinning knife
ooh good thing that cologne is good for
nothing yeah I got a beef up they're
gonna beef up ba e puffle Gary over
there all right Gary good job Gary and I
we got a road he'll get the hence little
doggie roasted cow tongue and extra
thick leather a lot of people don't like
the idea of eating something you can
pick you taste you back and believe me
nothing about this particular cow tongue
is gonna change their minds all right
well I got that which is great there's
rope tied to the fence post here all
right length of rope ah good and needle
I can go back to that other place try to
unlock that there's something buried in
the smoldering embers dig in oh I got a
red-hot poker what am I gonna do about
that red-hot poker
ooh deals hot damage instead of physical
why I reckon I hardly know her uh-huh I
get it that's funny I'm gonna keep the
varmints get a knife I know I can do
more damage otherwise but wow what is
happening too much oh my god did you see
my arms there no you notice some words
carved into the side of the outhouse
curly was here wait a second
you recognize that name curly curly
Butterfield The Legend of Curly's meat
looks like maybe this outhouse is worth
investigating
that was from the book back in the
doctor's house luckily you don't have to
actually go inside the outhouse because
once you open the door you find a map
scratched onto the inside of it the map
reveals the location of a mine just west
of the ranch and labeled Coleridge you
discovered a new map location there's an
inset map with the mine itself with big
with a a big X scrawled between three
streams triangular icons curious okay
you have one bottle of cow's milk I'm
about to turn me some butter baby
I got infernal butter great what do I do
about that oh I don't have lock whew to
your horror you see that every single
town the Butterfield Dairy Herd is now
an endless an infernal cow bound in
stone they're not dangerous unless you
go near them
oh I'm about to go near Oh alrighty then
you weird uncouth whatever the hell that
means
gonna beef up a bit stench you down make
a clone and then immune to poison well
ain't that a [ __ ] stick at least you're
too weak oh you're pretty you're pretty
not debate yeah
alright I got am a new note menudo geode
then the hurt a little well there's
still an effectively infinite number of
ungulates up there what would happen if
I killed them all is it possible try
alright dude oh dude what does the
menudo Gio do oh oh
sometimes a pocket of intestine remains
behind when a cow undergoes the
transition to an infernal unglue and you
get one of these a stone sphere full of
boiling tripe that sounds terrible
why would I do that to myself alright
I'll defy you and I'll find a way to
lockpick later but I don't know how to
upgrade my lock-picking ability also I
don't know what the hell I'm doing
alright let's go somewhere else
pull ridge mine where ever that's it Oh
unusual site an old boat out in the
middle of the desert it's just where a
beach you could call it beach but you
can't call it deserted because there's
someone in it that someone is a skeleton
wearing a helmet with horns on it it
looks pretty barred and is idly
polishing the dragon headed proud of his
ship you think maybe he's been there for
a long long time indeed I wanted to
bully him emotionally all right I'll
come back alright you surrounded and
they beat you up what
oh wait how did I cure matter and a
hornet if your anger level gets past
then higher than three you'll pass out
from range well I want to get
intimidating so that I can take care of
this
hello a dark metal hole hello out here I
will waiting not up for exploring a mine
better to staying here out with open
wind and sky not underground like zoo
dog okay I reckon I found you in a
cellar so I I can understand my
confusion here why you wouldn't want to
go down to do a dirt place anyway what
do we have here there's a row of lockers
here must have been used for storing the
personal effects of the fellas you used
to work in this mine
the first one is labeled Ellsbury WM and
doesn't have a lock on it the label on
the second one it's covered with some
kind of white goo third one is lays will
loose bed and as a combination on it
alright what's in the first one
Ellsbury's helmet a bottle of blood out
at home alright what about the second
one you open the door to reveal a
skeleton covered in the same white goose
who was on the outside of the locker you
get it this guy must have died after his
co-workers pulled a prank on him where
they stuffed him into his locker and
then filled it with shaving cream
I can't believe you dang jerk stuffed me
into a locker and then filled it with
shaving cream I died from that yellow
fiskerton confirming both your insight
and is very vengeful murderous intent
all right whoa oh god why are you
covered in goo oh you got so much hell
hey yeah yeah alright I'm gonna shoot
yeah we're gonna bap yeah and then
you're gonna die yeah dang ol dang ol
whatever you are I have no idea
buying alright that skeleton bones gold
chips loose teeth no goo I wanted some
goo okay combination lock here but you
don't know the combo righty then meat
mate I'll take that I've got a lot of
unrefined meat here whoa oh I just tied
my rope down didn't know that there's
dark down there
hey more meat all right cool what else
do I do about this dough hellooo this is
a spot Curly's toilet notes mentioned
okay weird there's a compass buried here
Curly's compass okay where do I do about
Curly's compass what does it do his
curly Butterfield's compass but that
dude must have always been lost because
this thing points every whichaway but
north examining the compass needle is
pointing it in generally north west dish
you mean where that doll went okay
there's this dude under find me nugget
under fine meat nugget meat a lot of
meat I'm going down deep don't like the
spiral one bit alright alright that's
weird
black fluid uses from the vein a
scabrous mass sits below it on the floor
great too bad vibrant
you want to stop looking at a spiral
right now a slit runs the length of the
meet vein let's reach inside it goes in
further than you'd expected it's warm
keep going
you're up it up to the shoulder when you
feel it a beating heart rip it out sure
alrighty then leave this barrel one bit
car looks frightening lis normal Oh No
righty then Guth looks like this guy
should have picked better friends welp I
got a pickaxe and I think enough life
full of nightmares because I don't know
what was going on down here but I'm
gonna cartwheel backwards out of this
guy's going to find curly butter
revealed treasure whatever that was so I
don't know where the combination would
have been oh well hey how's it going
alright whatever
let's get out of here what do we have
what do we have what do we have we got
to go to the old mission I suppose I
mean I know there's probably plenty of
places to wander ooh you're my cloud of
dust turns out to be a bandit on a horse
riding hell-for-leather for unknown
reasons well I know you I know them but
you don't you pull your horse up
alongside errs and match your speed hi
what's up where's the fire get bent
and/or lost I'll leave her alone you
know what I don't need to actually kill
you but alright whatever I'm going to
the old mission wherever that is hey
buddy how's it going ooh big stone
buildings clanging towers it's a church
what a religious place what all right
whatever you wait out here
ow tuna cactus that doesn't make no
sense hello how's it going pew pew pew
pew pew pew tea pie you're not a priest
so you shouldn't mess with any of this
stuff alrighty then hello sorry the
catacombs are off-limits oh but I've
always wanted to see the catacombs not
with our sister Mary's permission which
she's the only other nun here oh ok
alright then skating over to uh sister
Mary yeah
empty relic case for a skull oh my
goodness oh my goodness what's wrong
sister they came back they came back and
took him I couldn't stop him Oh slow
down okay
what happened our holy relics the same
just stormed up out of the catacombs and
took them back Wow I didn't know what to
do I thought maybe they'd fire me if I
tried to stop them the Cardinal will be
here any minute what am I gonna do start
with take a deep breath and try to calm
down okay what's your min I'm sister
Mary my name is mom Fleur now what is it
about Saints our missions our mission is
to protect three sacred relics on the
relic keeper it's my specific job to
look after them wait did they call you
memento man she shows you the rulers she
keeps tucked up in her sleeve no they do
not okay all right the Saints oh it's
too horrible they just they came to life
somehow they came up out of the
catacombs all skeletal and ghastly
looking let me it's probably blasphemy
to say that but I nearly fainted and
they took back their relics yes and if
they aren't recovered before the
Cardinal gets here I'll be in oh so much
trouble
uh-huh how much time is there well
actually he's months overdue so it'll
probably not all that urgent but still
I'll get him back oh thank you thank you
so much oh wait a second you're gonna
have to fight them to get the relics
back because that's probably blasphemous
too I mean probably but if black magic
brought them back to life then it's like
super blasphemous right so it evens out
oh dear the Cardinal is going to have
want to have a very long talk about this
we go ahead and do what you must I
suppose
[Music]
excuse me good luck down there all right
it's gate along hello it's empty
yo Deus huh wild up kick that over are
you sure there's a lot of them and
they're really mad maybe angering all of
them once isn't a great idea well let's
go for it was the worst that could
happen
ah huh spooky damage too much spook
alright fine then you wanna wanna spook
it up I got a load of spook for you oh
you got a lot of help
alright well shoot you you're gonna
clone oh it mean to poison well that
that makes this a lot simpler huh
so we're just gonna smack you around
until you dead huh okay
done and done no pile skulls ain't gonna
get the best of me I don't know what the
point of that was but I think I got a
lot of XP that I probably need to spend
on stuff mmm nice
gumption woo hey Mick intimidating Oh
fire a little more I'm gonna get that
suit I'm gonna get that real soon wait
yeah sells a gold tooth I'll take that
alright Luton religious catacombs well
that's fine
skull is twitching in an unnerving
fashion though I guess there's no way it
could be twitching that wouldn't be
unnerving
alright you stop that right now Pam oh I
am well now's easy I guess you're gonna
stop twitching now alrighty then skulls
sitting at a weird angle I guess that's
notable for some reason ooh
crushing the top of commemorative spoon
your treasure hunting senses are finally
home they're not very discriminating Oh
what does a souvenir spoon do for me
gives me moxie I'll take my shits pull
my [ __ ] porcelain cow please and thank
you also lets see skulls whispering to
you that doesn't seem right
scholars sounds like gibberish they'll
really creepy gibberish alrighty then
empty alcove there's a serial number
written on it oh hey this coaster let's
go oh I put that back alright these pile
of skulls has been cemented together for
some reason pick apart a creepy
whispering stone great what does that do
let's listen to it
this rock is really whispering up a
storm it's in some weird Dayak to that
you can barely understand though
wait no since the thick accent is all
listen more closely it wasn't Claire
Valley to the stone over the course of a
few minutes as whispers resolved into
comprehensible English the stop the
stone is whispering turns out to be
pretty boring it's mostly just trivia
about geology of Tennessee meaningless
to you unless you're planning a
spelunking trip soon oh well at least
you can understand the accent now an
Appalachian whispering skull that's
weird I don't know why I have that gonna
put that in my back pocket earth food
bones are jiggling and rattling in an
agitated fashion you whisper some
ancient words of appeasement to the
bones and they settled down a bit or
maybe I should have been whispering to
these bones instead of actually killing
them that would have been smart house
strictly decorative wait no hang on go
back a second what about this plaque
it's way too [ __ ] Oh days oh right
plaque here lies Saint Beavis after he
died his body kept trying to rise to
heaven but it was so heavy it just kind
of flopped around a bunch they had two
interim and a big stone sarcophagus to
put a stop to it here all right geez
they really know how to build heavy
stone sarcophagi back in the day I'm
gonna open it you grunting strained and
forced the heavy stone sarcophagus lid
open there's a skeleton inside holy crap
his bones are huge
whoa your bones are huge the health st.
P fish
Boatright Oh when a haymaker you kick
get hey mate yeah that reproduce nominal
beef you up well Oh
oh my oh my goodness Oh oh my oh oh oh
my oh my oh my oh my oh my oh my oh my
oh my oh my well then did ten damage oh
my oh my oh my
about stench damage hey that does damage
all right boy okay well there goes Gary
oh boy this ain't good
should have been shooting you from the
start all right I can take you I can
take your beef 'us come on beefy boy you
think you can beat me oh no beef let's
go down down alright well I got the same
beep beef is finger and I got Saint be
fist I don't know what those dude for me
see legs were so big he had to sit in
two chairs at the same time to muck
saloon 10 max HP I will take that oh my
God look at my big beefy bone it's quite
a bone same people it was so big that he
had more bone his little finger than
most people have in their entire arm
I got a beefy bone and that ain't no
euphemism and then same beef is some
kinds of Dark Ritual this ended weeks
ago weird
alright here lies Santa Cortana Cortana
she was drawn and quartered by heretics
and then the quarter that had her head
on it was beheaded the dismemberment was
so effective that nobody was able to get
her body to stay together even after she
was just bones
okay reassemble it okay you're pretty
sure you got the bones assembled in the
correctly all right well fight him no
but the very last minute the bones
five-part again seems like you all
accomplished was making them angry rats
Oh alrighty then well just don't seem
too bad let's go for the head though let
me beef up for excuse me I gotta get my
beefy bone ready to smack you around a
bit head down where fess ha ha ha you
guys suck you guys suck well ain't this
a dickering now well you guys suck too
bad I'm too smart I'm too strong you got
him since drown Wow okay well that was
easy
come on same cortada alright what did I
get me for that is ring mr. Calladine
speed real on again off again
relationship with the rest of court dad
as skeleton alright well that's one more
down it's a plaque here lies st. Pope he
was excommunicated for impersonating a
pope but there was some kind of
bureaucratic issues so they weren't
really done able to unbe defy him weird
okay why I'm a pope seriously alrighty
then mr. Pope sir what are you doing sir
are you really a pope hello alright sold
them you unleash a torrent of insults
that would make a sailor blush and a
sailor's mother ashamed of a sailor
Saint Pope's eyes narrow looks like you
finally managed to make him mad enough
to fight you have to jump on him this
time he's gonna get it with some breezy
Wham
excuse me sorry I apologize to this
missus
whoa someone's a cardinal well he's
going down but okay I thought my game
froze for a second there there the
Cardinal is yeah sleaze damage how did
you sleaze cabbage
excuse you don't be sleazing up I got
Pope Elvis you got fake Pope hat
all right great can I put on that fake
boob at what's mine do for me it's
pretty good it's pretty good but maybe I
should do the fake Pope at it's pretty
good Pope at like that bull pen yeah I
know I like my I like my hat it's good
all right
well did that don't know why I did that
boots is over here oh just some trash
clove chroot but stubs a black eyeliner
pencils that kind of stuff thing the
necromancers cultists are real litter
bugs it's strange though they even get
in here
ooh ley lines you say can I add that to
my diary you examine the weird diagram
but you can't make heads or tails of it
you just stick the note in your
necromancer journal for now all right
I'll read that up right ley line you'll
need to find somebody to help you with
that somebody smarter somebody news a
lot about magic huh so there's something
to these cultists say something reals
frames down in these cultists oh all the
artifacts that's right I was supposed to
find three artifacts I kind of equipped
one of them oopsy poopsy all right welp
I got everything i think you pew pew all
right Santa Cortez Santana
there we go you locked the skull back up
it seems very annoyed but sister Mary
thanks you effusive ly all right same
boobs pelvis all right I did it you're
weirdly looking finger bone in the
reliquary sister Mary looks delighted
you've recovered all the relics oh
praise be thank you I'm glad to have
helped sister I must reward you for your
efforts though we don't have much but
might you find these pants handy one of
our old priests left them behind
Nealon pants oh that's so sweet of you
thank you
what do I do with that I guess it's
better than my bean stained pants so
good old mule and pants for a little
added muscle I don't know how that works
but okay I'll take those with me if you
want I suppose I'll go to the Big Apple
I guess you'll find a flyer for a dynam
store up north it's charred around the
edges looks like it got blown here but
explosion you marked the address on your
map I find a dynamite Dan's discount
down to my dare house yeah I'll go to
that I'm gonna go to dynamite Dan's
discount down to my dare house oh it's
down about Dan Oh years of live dynamite
for a whole year how much is that that a
lot
then omelets I'll buy that sure
give me that dynamite I got ten now why
do I need this much dynamite this seems
like a bad idea to have this much
dynamite hello this place seeming a
little danger many old booms here
alright thanks thanks Gary thank you for
the inside I'm gonna go to the Big Apple
whoo discovered destroyed campsite well
no I'm sorry Big Apple I keep getting
distracted knapsack I got potted meat
most of the contents are trash from
being stomped on you do find a dented
can of potted meat though you also
notice that the knapsack has an ice
sheet strapped to the side but you don't
see a knife anywhere yes camp fire has
been thoroughly stomped and kicked on
someone who was real serious about fire
safety the stamp is a real mess which
says oh is trampled by a whole herd of
cows there's something odd about it
though
oh that it's your partner talk oh gosh
someone wasn't liking a person's camping
site Oh a more thorough inspection
reveals dusty boot prints on the tab
canvass cows don't typically wear boots
weird yeah II think maybe this used to
be a person ooh
this human is pooped Gary did not know a
human is to pooping popping is popped or
no we don't not in the sense I think you
mean anyway
this meat it is very large all of it a
human contains this meat well yeah I
could not bear to carrying all that so
squishy already then I kinda I'm
carrying a lot of meat myself
there are cow tracks leading away from
the mangled corpse probably wouldn't be
hard to follow them since you have
reason to believe these tracks may be
fake you could either follow them or
hidden
opposite direction I'll go in the
opposite way you head in the opposite
direction for about half a mile and
discover another campsite this one
occupied you observe the campers
carefully from a distance before
approaching they're dressed weirdly and
brightly colored baggy clothes and white
facepaint as you get closer you realize
they're dressed up as rodeo clowns gross
why would they do that
it doesn't seem to be enough rodeo
happening anywhere near here I'll
approach that camp hi hello white face
man's are uncomfortable making yeah no
kidding alrighty then
hello it's rodeo clown is playing a
harmonica the 2ds playing basically goes
doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot
hello nods says hello rodeo clown is
eating a comically large haunch of meat
he narrows his eyes you as if to say
mine this cloud is idly juggling a knife
howdy stranger he says with a smile
converse howdy stranger
howdy nice knife Thanks it was a
birthday present Oh was it your birthday
recently clown grins at you not my
birthday no wool you guys doing out here
camping you can tell by the campfire I
mean is there's no rodeo or circus
around here so why are you guys in rodeo
clown outfits know that no circus is up
north we're on break so we decided to
take in the sights what sights this is
the middle of nowhere nonsense check out
that cast over there at those mountains
and well only sound plenty of things to
see what circus event nearby a circus oh
you wouldn't have it's just a little
traveling show you aren't missing
anything what's called though clown
hesitates then shrugs
it's called Barnaby Bob's perfectly
normal traveling circus sideshow
perfectly normal what's it called that
in there it's a cue accuracy how far no
I visit oh pretty far too far for you to
worry about really how far it's up near
goblin Gulch wow that is really far
north it's right exactly too far you
walked all the way from there wait a
minute you guys walked all the way down
here from the northernmost part of the
territory for sight seen on your break
would you really
brakes we have a good union where's the
circus exactly why would you even want
to go there looks like - look don't
worry about it just tell me already I
want to enjoy some whimsical fricker
fricking merriment okay just tell me
where your damn circus is already clowns
eyes flash angrily but he quickly smooth
his expression with an appeasing smile
alright partner alright it's trying to
save you a long journey and all here
I'll mark it on your mem discover a new
Mac location Barnaby Barnaby Bob's
perfectly normal traveling circus
sideshow thanks Barnaby Bob how you
doing do you know anything about the
wreck camp nearby clown with the meat
chuckles quietly somebody's camp got
wrecks well as terrible whatever
happened oh I think you know what
happened the harmonica falls silent the
clown's eyes grow very cold he stops
toying aimlessly with his knife well now
I don't care much for that accusatory
tone in your voice mister what I mean is
looks like the work of cows you know now
that you mention it we did hear quite a
lot of ruckus coming from not too far
away a lot of you know mooing and so on
right boys you guys know a lot about
cows right now why would you assume that
just because we're clowns I figured it
comes with the territory but a good 20
years since a rodeo was an actual thing
you know so why'd you dress that way
dress
oh it's traditional after all isn't it
inconvenient how do you mean them to
make up in the baggy clothes yeah well
you might say we're used to it taking
that off would be more inconvenient
right fellows hard to talk to people in
the creeped-out oh do you think we're
creepy he leers it you showing yellow
teeth in the flickering light with the
campfire they look almost pointed Oh
relax partner this is the old stories
getting you worked up you mean the old
stories about how demon cows and even
clowns war against each other in Hell
and rodeo clowns dressed like that
because the rodeos were sort of like
reenactments of those battles you've
done your homework so what do you think
our demon crowns real yes maybe Dean
cows turned out to be real after all
it's sensible to keep an open mind but
you know a stranger if clowns did turn
out to be real this could be an awful
awkward predicament to find yourself
going now yeah I'm going your tent the
three man tent which probably sleeps
about 40 clowns alrighty then
well I'll be back once I get my my
intimidating skill up to four which
isn't gonna be long I just want to find
out what that last intimidating before I
actually fight them now I'm gonna go to
the Big Apple dig through the bags yes
cow punching great love it as he reached
the center of the clearing you were
simultaneously struck with a profound
sense of awe and a terrible stench as
you discover the largest road app
whether you ever seen you can't even
imagine now God here was it a giant
horse was it 200 normal-sized horses
acting collaboratively today they should
have sent a poet yeah they should have
wore my god what did I come here Siri
Wow oh wow my nose is disagreeing Carrie
why does it smell any better up close
clean it up make little dent in it whoa
whoa is that make a little dent in it
it's a bit smaller cleaning yep
shoveling [ __ ] way smaller yep almost
gone now
hooray yeah what was the point of AK
also where did I shovel it to okay
you are very digging is it enjoyment for
humans at all not even a little bit was
that enough exp not quite alright yeah
let me wander around for a bit ooh
snake spring over yonder I'll go to
snake spring why not
ooh tuna cactus I don't have forage and
yet no we're snakes for wool
[Music]
all right then a little weird endless
stream of snakes pour out of the hole in
the canyon wall imma grab a big one I'll
grab me a real big snake I got a beef up
Gary Gary's too weak does Gary not level
up like I do how it works works all
right I can get intimidating okay I got
intimidating rank for let me go back to
this clown campsite and see what's going
on with these damn clowns whoa he nearby
hissing sound alerts you through the
presence of a snake or at least
something that sounds like a snake which
turns out to be a goblin cooking
flapjacks on a flattened baking hot rock
the grace batter sizzles if the Goblin
pours out some more and then they look
up and give you a surprise look hi what
you doing out here
your thieving flapjacks baby dope I'm
Gary deal with it garyun the goblin have
a conversation they're talking quickly
and using long words so you can't make
out most of it but they seem to be
pretty amiable the chef even jacks up a
couple of flip flops for you I mean
flips up a couple of flapjacks now what
do they put in it scoffs I got goats
gobbling flapjacks hell yeah don't flash
games over to this demon clown over here
and see what the hell's going on oh I
can't oh no I can't intimidate him
anymore
oh no well just beat the [ __ ] out of you
all right well I'm gonna beat the [ __ ]
out of you specifically I am
oh geez oh my god
good thing I'm super unbelievably tough
against these goddamn clowns hey yeah
top this so giggly why it's so
gratefully giggly you stupid clowns okay
well got that guy well that's one pack
of demonic rodeo clowns it won't be
troubling people anymore
and boy you did not expect to be
thinking that sentence today look
through their stuff you poked around
their campsite for a bit but you don't
find anything of value from the leaders
knife and a ticket of the circus well
the harmonica maybe but that clown had
his lips all over it
you got a clown knife and a circus
ticket you also find a note it's one of
the league clown's pockets you seems to
be orders to check out an abandoned
tannery not far from dirt water probably
a bad idea to let these guys wander
around near town so maybe you should
investigate alright
Danny's tannery shudder so I imagine
what would have happened if I ever
intimidated him I would have gotten
these orders without killing them same
result as always so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know I'm
doing the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]